اجتماع عسكري قد يكون الاهم منذ بدايه
الحرب الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا
خلال لقائه مع كبار الضباط العسكريين
تعاهد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن يوم
الاربعاء بتحقيق روسيا لاهدافها المعلنه
في اوكرانيا كما اكد على تعزيز قدرات
قواته المسلحه والتركيز بشكل خاص على
تطوير القوه النوويه في البلاد
القتالي الثالوث النووي هذا هو الضمان
الرئيسي للحفاظ على سيادتنا وسلامتنا
الترابيه وعلى تكافؤ الاستراتي وميزان
القوه العام في العالم هذا العام تجاوز
مستوى الاسلحه الحديثه في القوات النوويه
الاستراتيجيه بالفعل واحدا و90 في المئه
خلال المؤتمر قام وزير الدفاع الروسي
باقتراح لزياده عدد الجنود بالاضافه الى
رفع سن الخدمه العسكريه من الضروري زياده
عدد القوات المسلحه الى مليون ونصف جندي
منهم
695,000 جندي متعاقد
وكان رئيس الروسي قد قام بتجنيد ما يزيد
على 300,000 جنديا احتياطيا لدعم الغزو
الروسي
انه يتفق مع مقترحات وزير الدفاع